le doigt appuyé et on les colle ses lois
c'est justement pour mieux comprendre
les résidents sourds qu'une dame a
demandé à la direction de la résidence
saint eugène de mettre en place des
cours de langage décennies au printemps
dernier ah oui c'est vrai le cours d'eau
et lescure en ligne de la fondation des
sourds du québec et j'ai regardé ça et
je me suis dit pourquoi pas je peux la
prendre avec eux en même temps on va
avoir du plaisir du mans temps à
défendre
en presse à madame mais c'est devenu
beaucoup plus qu'une simple activité se
serait laissé l'école je me rappelle un
car a fait ça fait travailler le macaque
j'absorbe si j'avais de la mémoire
j'aimerais encore plus somme je les
oublie de restitution mais s'ils font
parce que des fois on veut le parler aux
gens s'ils ont si quelques petits monts
mais le non l om
comment le formule vous rappelez vous la
peine de mort
c'est des gens qui depuis longtemps ma
fondation sont des salles d'une enfant
tu tiens des choses comme ça il est en
train taquin le jeu se suivent les
résidents malentendants véritable expert
en lsq participent ils se font un
plaisir d'aider s'ils sont vraiment
heureux qu'on fasse l'effort d'entrer en
contact avec eux
madeleine sainte croix est devenue la
traductrice du groupe nouvelle ag
l'atalante de mission au plan jeune
femme aux traits communs selon moi
autant que ça fait tomber des barrières
entre les tentant d'enfiler s'ouvre que
même pour les gens qui participent aux
coûts les gens s'affirment plus sont
moins gênés de dire bonjour et tout ça
puis ça amène beaucoup de bonheur
beaucoup de bonne humeur en tout cas
dans les copies dont ça va bien très
bien dans cette résidence à loyer
abordable
il y a une dizaine de résidences ou sur
170 pour l'instant est ici à nourrice
despatie radio canada montréal